[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we will
have you guys seen a khabees recent
recent post yeah what happened okay so
you know what went down cuz you were
there you saw the whole fight go down
and then um there's all these I guess
sanctions and things that are being put
on khabib like they're withholding the
money from him you know there's gonna be
there's gonna be penalties
hey man has team - he made his whole
team yeah and he recently wrote this
post you should check it out word for
word but the essence of it is why didn't
you punish McGregor when he was doing
all these things you still let him find
you still let this thing go down and
then the the whole summary of it is is I
see it I see his point of view and
there's just so much more honor and his
way of thinking then what's going on
with McGregor and everything else so one
is like McGregor is playing a game of
entertainment and this is a spectacle
sport and khabib is like this is my life
I take this serious this is honor and
you I'm defending it so it's it's I
think it's just a clash of culture and
ideas well hobby doesn't also understand
- is that when you did that you did it
during a fight and so it's not just the
UFC it's the Nevada State they're coming
after you - yeah so he doesn't he
doesn't see that you know what I mean so
what Conner do I mean Conner did get
punished it wasn't to that severity but
he did it outside of a fighting ring he
got punished the way he should have
outside of the Ring exactly so you did
it within a fight and he doesn't see a
difference you know so it's that it's
that honor thing so you're being
actually attacked not even just by the
UFC it's by the Nevada State Commission
so like that's the thing he doesn't
understand right now that's one thing
that a lot of the fans don't understand
- it's like it'd be like like they what
McGregor did was in the hallway and it's
unbraid casted kabhi did it on broadcast
television in a fight so there's way
more way different rules but
even though he doesn't understand them
what I do like about him he was like he
was roles with all these other fighters
and a lot of them are highly unknown but
they're just still on the roster and he
was saying if you're gonna fire I think
those names are here yeah
like that or zeri he was like if you're
gonna let go that dude for punching
Connor for Connor hit him first which I
will saw the video over and over right
yeah thank you comment that the Boomer
hits on my ping his hat falls off yeah
he was like if you're gonna if you fire
him - losing me - and I'm like damn
that's [ __ ] dope loyalty that type of
brotherhood and loyalty you don't really
see in like American sports because if
it's American they could be on the same
team but [ __ ] I still gotta feed my
family exactly it's a lot more about the
self it's all buttons it's it's like so
there's no it's like this so could be
what he's doing to me it's like when we
talked on JK news about oh you know we
were provoked so then we punched them
that's illegal
it's not okay but I kind of agree with
those rules and I think the same thing
applies in Hawaii where it's like oh you
are disrespecting and provoking other
people and it's like in other groups and
cultures it's okay to say whatever you
want as long as you're not violent it's
okay to provoke people it's okay to make
people angry or whatever but then it's
like oh once you do start throwing fists
then you call the police right so it
depends on what you agree on what is
right and wrong and that's why I mean
like I said like in this situation like
I think Abebe is the good guy no matter
what but - Connors credit though just
please like those rules Connor didn't
press charges he goes [ __ ] it don't
press charges I just want to find him
again yeah that's pretty dope of Connor
you guys pretty dope and even beyond
he's being dope that's how much he's
just he's just a business guy yeah you
thought it mean it's literally not
personal for him yeah so for him I think
even in his mind he's like bro I just
made you a [ __ ] few million dollars
man like we should be on the same
[ __ ] pinguin take shots together yeah
puppet with one is a showman and the
other one's a warrior yeah and I think
the one thing is that Connor actually
understand that Connor still a
competitor he still wants to fight the
top top elite whatever yeah there's a
one
'we [ __ ] match he wants to go back
and avenge his loss so he's still a
fighter but he really understands I just
made you money yeah you know but Habib
is like no I'm just a fighter dude this
is my honor this is like you were saying
so for me it's just kind of like I wish
that he could just push that aside and
understand that you're still fighting a
great competitor so it's still within
that martial ABS type of thing but
Conner is really just trying to make a
check yeah I think it's like with any
televised sport it's sports
entertainment entertainment this is so
some fighters fear more on the
entertainment side of some severe Weimer
on the sports side yeah I think the the
main thing about though is what when he
jumped over and started attacking
outside and caused all that danger to
just like the spectators and everybody
else he could you could have punched
Drake dude the curse of Drake every time
he's supporting like a team or like a
particular athlete they all knew that's
tight imagine if they Shaun him to when
like no like we went to Vegas and Shaun
was the bad they should [ __ ] Photoshop
him on every ball sack of every elite
athlete dude this guy is nut hugging the
ankle he is he nut he's oh he's a
[ __ ] Lakers warrior what else man
like you know he doesn't even have a
favorite yeah does that matter
uh-huh what if you just like to that one
person because they're homies like no
they're not homies they are not homies
they know you were that tight with
absolutely not dude I think also in the
sports world you can't wear every team's
Jersey guy that war could be vinegar
it's intentional that's not basketball
football that doesn't work so fine it's
known also fight
okay so fight sports it's an individual
sport right exactly
wrap your hood in us in local sports
like I don't know how long please man
replica later when Golden State was
sucking ass he's still rocking Golden
State til I die I don't give a [ __ ]
right and if they come up hell yeah they
go back down like Sacramento Kings are
dying right now
but that's hey that's local sports we're
a lot better this season I mean Bagley
dude we're a lot better this season come
on you gotta admit I got a man hell yeah
dude I mean we're not good a lot better
yeah let's talk about the [ __ ] Lakers
though [ __ ] preseason games dude man
it was such a dope [ __ ] game you want
to talk about an offensive ass [ __ ]
gay man that [ __ ] was tight what's good
on the offense dude it's just warriors
and [ __ ] Lakers are such high pace
[ __ ] offensive team amazing that 45
Warriors won that a three-pointer that
LeBron made Lakers won that one dude
yeah it was just like the score look all
that last white dude the ramp fouled out
in a preseason game yeah crazy the
seasons gonna be but literally that game
who followed up Durant
Cameron it's a preseason game right but
that game was literally a precursor to
show yo we're coming to [ __ ] you up you
know I mean cuz look who we owe like
LeBron doesn't have to go that hard on a
preseason game you should be safe guard
up exact maybe was a lot of people count
it shows you how excited he wants to
come to LA dude but LA dude they have
they have [ __ ] Rondo so he's making
place where everybody did oh I [ __ ]
love it
he does look here tonight New Jersey I
can't afford them they're too expensive
they're not that expensive it's still
like you know it's not that I can't
afford it but it's like if you want to
go to the backpack area you might just
watch it at home yeah it's a lot mobile
arena yeah it's like a hundred and fifty
it's like a hundred and fifty bucks for
like this [ __ ] we should catch a Laker
game though the next mile a couple acres
Warriors tickets
hit me up I'm down it's 800 for
nosebleed
the prices but that's like because if
you're literally watching like an
Olympic team go after an Olympic team
yeah that's true it's [ __ ] wildly
better than the finals honestly
Stephenson [ __ ] Rondo LeBron oh god
dude I'm not I hate [ __ ] hate the
Lakers right but it's [ __ ] fun
watching them play though see that's
local sports yep whatever I don't know I
break the roof yeah cause like the wood
with fighting I don't even follow anyone
out of here they just watch a fighter
until they stop being good yeah the
loyalty is very short yeah I don't buy
any and I feel bad BJ Penn till I die
even though he keeps getting his ass
kicked over and over and over and over
again I feel with Diego Sanchez oh you
might do those hatches yeah cuz he five
to all hard but sometimes like he's so
stupid he just he just gets knocked and
he just gets knocked out I just remember
him from [ __ ] tough dude like he was
undefeated for a while yeah I was like
damn dude this guy's from tough but I
never really liked him as a fighter cuz
I don't like a style you know what's
craziest John Jones is from tough has
produced some really really gonna do a
Piers Anthony Pettis and [ __ ]
Ferguson we're on the same season a
tough that's why watching the fight was
crazy
the ultimate Vitamix show that's how
they pick fighters it's like American
Idol before fighter yeah that fight dude
Anthony Pettis and Ferguson was my
favorite fight that night that was
really actually Pettis to win so bad now
cuz I hate Ferguson [ __ ] weird it's a
weird one [ __ ] weird yeah it was just
fun it was like it looked like just more
fun good [ __ ] cool like Ferguson
looks like you know that dog from Koko
shoot up here that looks like you're
looking dude man and if you see the way
he trains he's a [ __ ] maniac
who the [ __ ] like but three days before
a fight he goes I'm training and this
was balancing on ankles that's why he
that's why he heard some tripping over
cords and he's [ __ ] weird dude busted
his knees wearing sunglasses like in a
darkroom like the heavy Pettis was he
did he do Taekwondo before Anthony
Pettis well you know if anybody loves at
VP I don't know his background per se
but he's always been a great striker cuz
he does like tornado kicks and [ __ ] like
that that's why people were excited
seeing his open workout his [ __ ]
striking got on to another level and now
so you know if you saw in that fight did
you see him just come out with that bah
boom he was waiting for that dude and so
when I saw him crack Furguson
I was like dude he's done but Ferguson
that every [ __ ] mask is crack in the
face like that and nothing happens he's
not human he's my chin he's somersaults
it off yeah dude that [ __ ] somersault
was so good that was genius I was like
dude that's next one is crazy
that was just was not next-level that
was just some weird [ __ ] no it was
genius because it rocked him a little
bit and then what was Tara's gonna do he
can't attack them cuz this wasn't a
[ __ ] human to follow up nothing is
this Ferguson has you give him way to
discuss is just talking weird and I
think that's like to his advantage
people don't know what the [ __ ] he's
gonna dance like a random he's a he used
to be everybody they all were boogie boy
his arms are so long his [ __ ] elbows
are [ __ ] furious he's just weird dude
I'm who the [ __ ] uses as this as a
threat I'll [ __ ] ankle pick you I got
such a weird [ __ ] threat to say that
I love that [ __ ] fighting sport man
it's like the best he's still film the
tough yet it still goes on right now
they're just in Vegas where they have
that house and everyone or is not sure
if it changes but I'd loved when I saw
it it was in Vegas yeah you know was
trying to get on tough front arm we're
tight point I would love that
he wants to once he gets all healed up
and he has a couple warm-up fights you
want to get onto I really hope Ron gets
it
so one that he was saying like you have
to obviously be on Dana's radar oh yeah
which he is in the UFC already so he
knows like everyone that's in
development now he just has to bring up
his following where before it's like
just being a good fighter is good enough
but it is like sports entertainment
business well maybe we could help him
with that yes we got yes bring up his
following and then most importantly has
to get all of his like shoulders and
stuff fixed which is you know what my
favorite season of tough was is when
Rampage Jackson when the coach and he
was going at one of the fighters and
they'll call him titties he broke the
door I got so bad at him because he was
a heavyweight but that guy was a pretty
terrible fighter but he would not stop
calling this guy kids on the show and
he's like a fighter like you don't want
that this do you go step with me one
more time to see what happens but he
kept on making so many titty jokes I was
dying laughing it actually felt bad for
the guy because he kept on saying he
kept busting to him god nope
would you ever would you ever do amateur
fight oh I I really thought about it
because like ages Alma did a profile at
40 I really so if I do if I continue to
do like boy toy I think if I did I
wouldn't do more toy with you MMA but it
would have to be like three years from
now so I'll see what happens in three
years so if I continue to Train like 4.4
times a week I can predict what's gonna
happen to you in three years what
David's gonna be like this on the
[ __ ] gurney what's gonna happen I'm
gonna swing I'm a swing then I'm gonna
punch myself in the face but fighting is
pretty fun but I don't know if I don't
what I kind of realized too is I don't
have the mentality to want to hit
somebody in the face like I don't I
don't enjoy it like I like light
sparring but going in and just going and
cracking somebody so for exempt a crack
you hard first
well that's dipper so this is what hey
hey
if someone cracks me first I already
feel like well this is what happened - I
don't like feeling angry I don't like I
don't think you should fight angry
either so I don't like fighting angry
yeah so if I go into a mature yeah so if
I go into a fight angry and that's the
only way you can get me to hit you hard
then I'm not a no because you can't
think clear exactly so I don't think
that's a smart thing to because like I
was sparring this guy and this is same
situation with you learning that guy
they kept on kicking you
yeah and then you cracked him to the leg
so this guy so we're like sparring right
do comes up he hooks me whoa we have no
mouthpiece
no [ __ ] headgear Bob gets me in the
job my jaw was stored for two weeks
right he had me so [ __ ] hard I was
like yo chill out he goes no you can't
take it like oh yeah and so and it was
if someone told me that I think I'd be
angry yeah and so I'm like sitting there
and like by the way if you guys don't
know like even getting hit like at 30%
and you don't have a mouthpiece you
could shatter your teeth yeah he hit me
hard he tried swinging at me again and I
think what happened was he knew that I
was on YouTube or something and he was
trying to make like a show out of it
right so when you do these [ __ ]
rounds you're like switching from
sparring partner to sparring partner so
I got so [ __ ] mad I just looked at
I'm as I okay I was like don't do that
again man like seriously we know that
any mouthpieces I'm not good nice dude
I'm like laughing enough so you got me
again I said [ __ ] it I just leg kick
them with all my [ __ ] mic crack them
down and build out yeah I kicked them
hard dude nice because we were only
supposed to do like hand stuff but I got
so [ __ ] mad I just like shin kick
them right in the [ __ ] thigh and
after that I felt bad yeah but it didn't
make me feel good you know you know what
I mean but and there's like people like
that that you meet when you spar and
they don't understand this is a light
sparring situation you meet the people
like that in the gym all the [ __ ]
time and I do yeah I don't understand
what the [ __ ] problem was he trying
to knock out my [ __ ] teeth I'm super
down to do it amateur fight I think the
thing that I that makes me not want to
do it is I don't like the pre-fight
nerves so even with my powerlifting meet
probably two or three days leading up to
the powerlifting me I don't really sleep
there cuz I'm just anticipating the meet
the weight cut all that stuff so it just
there's just all these nerves around you
and that that feeling of like oh [ __ ] I
have to do you know you ever have that
feeling where you gotta like have a like
talk to someone about something really
really serious and you're like okay now
it's it's gonna be that time where I
have to get this off my chest and
that feeling I get that feeling for
powerlifting meets and I can only
imagine how much worse they would
probably be if I had a fight and then so
now I have two days of going through
that and not sleeping good and then
because the fighting and sparring I'm
always down to do that but it's just the
pre-fight nerves oh my god like that
feel would you would you do uh one in
like a couple of to three years or yeah
if I'm ready I mean I I slow down your
language you guys are so [ __ ] down
boy I think for a lifetime I'll probably
do karate because it's if soft contact
right even though there are mistakes and
things in risk of injury but you know
full-contact sport is a different thing
so I think if I could get better and I'm
more comfortable with myself I'll do it
cuz then I can control a lot more and
I'm not just wildly swinging at this
point right now going 100% it's
guaranteed risk of injury whereas like I
think the better you get the more you
can kind of gauge the situation and not
get yourself in stupid moves like if I'm
still dropping my hands and I'm still
doing stupid mistakes
then it's a lot more dangerous I'll put
it to you like this though was the last
time you guys went to like an amateur
fight man I haven't gone PI over ten
years we used to support our gym buddies
like when we did MMA and we would watch
over and over so I remember how trashy
these people are though what do you mean
like how bad some of these hammocks oh
my god some of the guys really bad some
of them are [ __ ] terrible good like
some of them are really good too though
yeah but you wouldn't get matched up
with somebody like that though I
guarantee you like they're not gonna
like that dude is you're not gonna be
matched up with some dude that's had
like seven amateur fight you know what I
mean so like even if you drop your hands
you have your chin there's some pretty
[ __ ] bad people at these matches like
they have absolutely no business being
an amateur fighter they just want that
title of amateur fighter and I guarantee
you probably like them up by pretty bad
yeah cuz I've seen it where these guys
come in and they're just like in the
corners like throwing punches
oh no I'm like oh my god this guy's
gonna get murdered like I saw this one
match I would feel bad I saw this one
match where this guy literally got so
[ __ ] upset because the guy that he
was fighting arguably he was jacked he
looked like he could fight comes in
guy lifts him up double lake dips him on
his ribs bah knocks him out and the guy
was so mad because he trained for so
long to fight this guy and he literally
had zero training and the guy would just
went like this he goes but why did they
let him in good that these are hot
that's how get off some of these amateur
matches there are those pros that are
like dude you should just sign up for a
fight and you're like [ __ ] yeah and they
just signed up tomorrow yeah that's sad
man
dude it's like that to you I think if I
was in that situation I wouldn't go I
would have unleash on them I don't know
I feel bad like you wouldn't know though
weird he was training for a fight you
could tell that guy was ready he was
like loose ready to go and I was like yo
this is gonna be a dope thing because
that guy was jacked looks like he
trained literally double flip them
smashed him on his rid of the guy
knocked out and it was done I was like
dude and that guy was pissed cuz he
trained so hard so you never know what's
gonna happen
yeah I don't know I'd like to though
while I'm young but like remember that
show it was was it fighter or whatever
but there was like a like a like a
six-part documentary of that actor Idris
Elba dude yes yes yeah yeah and then he
went through all this different training
to fight his muay thai match and all
that now was pretty cool [ __ ] was that
old Jack Skye that broke up that with
this forearm yeah that's pretty cool so
that's a style that does body
conditioning I think it's gojira or some
[ __ ] like that but those guys it's
they're like human [ __ ] iron skillets
cast iron yeah man and if you train hard
enough dude like man it's crazy what the
human body can do you could break trees
you could break bats you can [ __ ] do
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] I'm delicate man
[ __ ] that I'm gonna make you horny err
if I did an amateur fight hornier yeah I
don't know if that the [ __ ] back leg
gets look at me I like man [ __ ] a lot
yeah I don't like if if the guy is like
very like a little too plain and like
you me said I pick up Dookie with his
hands yeah I know the should I complain
like what's magic to you this is getting
led to a little aggressive or or what's
magic all of that like like just getting
I don't know just like roughhouse little
bit Ikea desk yes [ __ ] like that like
take me back to the caveman ages you
know what I mean where they're just like
the stuff that you actually complain
about is kind of the stuff you like I
love it yeah you keep on picking up
Dookie pick up wanna make you horny if
Casey did an amateur fight what would it
make you go that's pretty dope well if
you want yet what the fact that he
stepped in arenas no that's already like
the 1% of the population most people are
too scared to even step in a ring to
begin that's me sometimes like whenever
he'll get like he'll puff up his jets or
whatever will be like at a bar and then
someone steps on my toes and then okay
oh and you like hey whatever like he'll
do some straight on like we I mean we
did full-contact fighting but then we
were so much more skinnier and smaller
and younger that and we didn't connect
as hard and we didn't know as much and
our competition wasn't as we were kind
of all matched up you guys were urgence
yeah
[Music]
[Music]